I remember my genetic report, the BR, the BRCA was highlighted, but the genetic test that my
oncologist ran because I was under 50 showed BRCA as negative, were the test looking at different
genes. So remember, the BRCA genes, there's dozens and dozens of BRCA genes, they're gene
family. So when we say, oh, I am defects in my rocket genes, that means you have defects in
that BRCA gene family. Now, they're only looking like I said before, typically, they're only
looking at a couple of those genes, even when they run the test, they're only testing for a couple
of those genes in that gene family. To me, that's silly. Oh, just because these are the most
researched and these ones are, you know, the most research to me, the issues and those are negative.
Well, if you had tons of defects in some of the other ones, then it's like, okay, well,
this could be an issue. So again, when you have defects in a gene, it doesn't mean the gene's not
going to work, but doesn't mean that, you know, you're doomed for a life. It just means that you have
a greater chance of that gene not functioning as well as if you didn't have any defects in it.
You don't know why the medical profession truncates things so often. It makes no sense to me.
Is it really, they're already charging you a bloody fortune to run a test like that? They're
charging your insurance bloody fortune. Why don't they do it? Well, it's just like having somebody go
into the ER and they do, uh, I've seen this so many times, they did this. They went into the ER with
all these issues. They do a CBC, but they don't do a differential. What the heck? It costs you like
another $2 to do it. I just don't understand it. They go to the, they pick the cheapest thing.
I don't get it. And then you get less information.